well first of all I welcome the
president to Belfast it's always good to
see the president of the United States
in Northern Ireland the United States is
our closest Ally and we recognize that
the importance of that relationship to
the United Kingdom I welcome the fact
that he made reference to the enormous
contribution that the Ulster Scots made
to the foundation and building of the
United States of America I think it's
important to have that recognition given
some of the comments that have been made
in the past but fundamentally he in the
conversation we had recognized that it's
for the leaders in Northern Ireland to
make the decisions about our future he
is not here to interfere he made that
clear and to be honest he didn't seek to
apply any pressure he recognizes that it
is the political leadership here that
needs to take the decisions to move
things forward to apply pressure says
he's in listening mode but he must have
asked you to get back into Power sharing
no actually he didn't uh what he did say
was that the United States stands ready
to support and help Northern Ireland
that he will continue to encourage
investment in Northern Ireland the
United States is our biggest foreign
direct investor here there are thousands
of jobs created by American companies of
course we'd always like to see more
American businesses here but that
investment can't continue while there's
no functioning governments can it well
we are continuing to see investment in
Northern Ireland we're continuing to see
including American businesses expand in
Northern they do very well here we have
a business environment in which
companies coming into Northern Ireland
can Thrive and I think we'll see more of
that in the future even with that power
sharing being restored well of course we
want to see the political institutions
back up and running but the United
Kingdom is our biggest Market by a
country mine we sell far more Goods
within the United Kingdom than we do to
the rest of the world combined that's
why I want to get this right I want to
ensure that Northern continues to of
access to the whole of the United
Kingdom and its internal market and that
the arrangements to facilitate trade
with the EU don't get in the way of our
ability to trade within our own country
you can see some Edge integrating about
I want to just finish just really
quickly on that one and you think that
what has been agreed this wins a
framework does impede that that's the
problem it doesn't actually resolve it
especially soon ago and tell us I think
there's further work that needs to be
done and we will engage with the
government to see what further uh can be
delivered in terms of respecting and
protecting Northern Ireland's ability to
trade within the United Kingdom and its
internal Market but you voted against it
sorry Sam you voted against it wasn't
there an alternative can you voted for
it and then worked out the details well
we need to see more of the detail of
course and we'll continue to engage with
the government towards that end I want
to see a solution that works for
everyone in Northern Ireland
um so Jeffrey are very struck the way
that you've talked about today it's
emollient you welcome the problem uh the
President coming over uh to Northern
Ireland so he's always welcome in
Northern Ireland that the tone that you
take it's just so sharply different from
some of your colleagues we heard uh Jim
Shannon uh coming on half an hour ago
much more instinctively critical of uh
uh President Biden coming here today I
suppose the big question for me is will
the dep always move as one in this issue
if the Sammy Wilson's and the Ian paisy
Juniors objects to the winter framework
but others in the dup perhaps more
enthusiastic about going back into
Stormwind would you ever leave them
behind well we are very focused as a
party on what we need to achieve and
actually we're moving forward as one
party uh to secure our objectives look
of course people will reflect on some of
the things that has been said in the
past things that were unhelpful but I
welcome the fact fact that today the
president's speech was I feel more
balanced and measured it acknowledged
the contribution the enormous
contribution that that people from
Northern Ireland our ancestors made to
the foundation and building of the
United States of America and I think
that's something everyone in the duv
would welcome and I also welcome the
fact that the president didn't today
seek to put pressure on to say to
political leaders you must do this or
you must do that of course he wants to
see the institutions restored don't we
all but it has to be on the basis of
firm foundations and and that requires
unionists as well as nationalist support
but 25 years ago you were the person
that walked out of the room ahead of the
Good Friday agreement signing ahead of
the event that we're that we're here to
commemorate now it feels like you're a
much more consensual figure in all of
this if Sammy Wilson if in paisy junior
walks away would you stop them
well look uh as a party we always try to
move forward together and uh I value the
the views of my colleagues we continue
to work on these issues we have a shared
objective which is to see our
institutions restored on firm
foundations and that's what we're
working to deliver I mean those firm
foundations there was
mentioned from Jim Shannon earlier that
they feel he feels like the Windsor
framework doesn't guarantee northerlands
place in the union is that how you see
what's in that document I think that's
why the government needs to go further
and needs to ensure that as the
government of the United Kingdom it does
what it committed to do way back at the
beginning of 2020 which was to protect
northland's place within the United
Kingdom under our ability to trade with
the rest of the United Kingdom but isn't
the Belfast Good Friday agreement
guarantee uh this area's Union with the
rest of the United Kingdom that's
already underpin what is in place and
suddenly the protocol undermined it and
what we need to ensure is that the
damage and the harm caused to the union
by the protocol is properly repaired I
mean you were sitting in the room there
listening to President Biden singing
this to Michelle O'Neill the first
Minister designate what what did you say
when you were sitting next listening to
the president well uh I converse with
all of my colleagues on occasions like
this we didn't talk politics and I am
focused on what we need to do and to
achieve to deliver the restoration of
the political institutions in Northern
Ireland I mean you've got local
elections council elections coming up on
May the 18th there is some suggestion
that you could I mean it's not going to
suffer for assembly members but lose
some Council seats because of the fact
that power sharing has not been restored
How concerned do you are going to lose
votes to more Hardline parties well I
want Power sharing to be restored on a
firm foundation that's what we're
working to achieve and I'll be taking my
message to the country during the local
elections and asking people to support
the dup to finish the job we want to get
this right we want to get it done
that's the message of the country did
you see we should see that this morning
I will be meeting the Prime Minister
when he visits Belfast next week okay
and what will be the message to him
you're gonna send him back to the EU
again to try and rework that Arrangement
that he said that he worked so hard to
bring to you well actually I think it is
a matter for the UK government alone
itself to protect nor lands players
within the United Kingdom I'm not asking
him to close off our trading
opportunities with the EU I'm asking him
to protect our trading opportunities
with the rest of the United Kingdom